hi everyone i'm jeevana hector and i'm
julian theo and we're both customer
engineers at google cloud
and we're very excited to share with you
the launch of the second phase of our
google cloud technical guides for
startups a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud our mission begins with you and
we're invested in building your business
successfully with innovative technology
and holistic support from google cloud
hence whether you're in the early stage
of product market fit or you've just
received your next round of funding
we're here to help you grow with the
successful competition of phase one
where we created a series of videos to
help beginners as well as early stage
startups that might be in their
pre-trial phase to build manage and
deploy new applications onto google
cloud from start to finish
we're delighted to launch phase 2 the
build series
this series is designed to help startups
launched on google cloud to optimize and
scale their existing deployments to
reach target audience this is an
initiative to help you build on google
cloud and also understand how other
startups are leveraging our products and
solutions and we're very excited to
share with you the launch of our brand
new website which contains many useful
resources for startups such as our
on-demand videos as well as our resource
handbooks to accompany startups as they
start build and grow on google cloud to
add on these handbooks have links to
many resources such as hands-on labs
documentation articles and many more
which can help you to aid your learning
as they go beyond the topics that we
cover and you can leverage them to the
fullest we will continue to update these
resource handbooks as we embark along
the journey
in this build series we're navigating
through a whole trail of topics on
google search we kicked off with this
launch video to give you an overview of
what to expect from the build series
which builds upon the start series we
have the link to the start series
playlist linked in the description box
below we would suggest you navigating
through that if you're new and are just
getting started on google cloud and in
our second video we'll be sharing with
you more details about our startup
programs that are designed to help you
as you build and grow your business and
following that we'll be diving into a
series of data videos beginning with
understanding firestore after which
we're also diving into data analysis
with bigquery a popular product amongst
our customers and you'll find out why
following that we'll show you how you
can use your spark and hadoop clusters
faster with dataproc
and look into how you can manage your
processing pipelines with data flow as
well as data visualization with data
studio and then we move on to another
hot topic of technology machine learning
where we'll be understanding and using
ready-to-use machine learning apis and
understanding how to build your own
models with vertex api our umbrella
platform for any machine learning
product we'll then further look into api
management and how you can manage your
apis with apogee we'll then do a
security deep dive and last but not
least go through cloud tasks and cloud
scheduler
that will be a wrap up of the build
series and from there we will move on to
our final grow series
we are thrilled to be working alongside
you on your startup journey to explore
concepts step-by-step guides and use
cases across industries
up next in the build series in our
second episode we'll be sharing with you
more about google cloud's very own
startup programs designed to support
your startup as you build and grow your
business
this includes
firstly a broad overview of the various
startup programs available the google
for startups cloud program for funded
startups up to series a providing
business financial and technical support
our migration incentive program for
later state startups looking to offset
the cost of migrating cloud services and
infrastructure to google cloud
and with that that's a wrap please like
and share this video and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel as well to
stay updated with our series
hang tight and we'll see you on the
other side
[Music]